- This, I knew at
a very early age,
the most cultured country in
the world built Auschwitz.
There's this old question,
how did the people who
gave us Beethoven and Bach
give us Auschwitz?
And I always found, it's
an interesting question,
but it's somewhat
of a non-sequitur.
Why does having
Bach and Beethoven
inoculate you against
becoming evil?
The ease with which a
civilization can turn, morally,
that's what Germany taught,
and I see that happening
in the United States.
This, I always believed
was the kindest country.
I know it has
rotten people in it,
just as rotten countries
have kind people in it.
But as a country, when people
wanted help after earthquakes,
they didn't ask for Belgium.
When people used a flag
to rebel for liberty,
like in Hong Kong, they
didn't take the Swedish flag.
But look what's happening.
(mysterious music)
- All right, Prager,
here we go again.
I will tell the people that
we had a moment to chat
before we just sat down,
and we realized that we have
not seen each other in person
in about 14 or 15 months,
because it was a few weeks
before my first son was born.
And you said to me,
well, why don't I let
you tell the people
what you said to me right
before the child was was born.
- I said I thought I had,
in fact, seen your kids.
Well, there was-
- But you haven't as
far as I could tell.
So you may have dreamt
that you've seen them.
- Yes, so it shows you,
I don't know if this
is a good or bad thing,
the power of photos.
- Yeah, I've sent you
a lot of pictures.
- Yes.
- I sent you two
a lot of pictures.
- From the beginning, exactly.
- And then I couldn't remember
if you had seen them either.
- That is really funny,
we should ask them.
- We should ask the kids.
- [Dennis] Yes, exactly.
- Well, they're not
talking just yet.
They're not talking.
- No, no.
- Then I said to you,
"Well, do you remember
holding them?"
Because I know, just-
- Yeah, that would
be a giveaway, yeah.
- And we have no recollection.
- Yeah, I remember
holding photos.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, okay,
that's fair enough.
- But, I did see you.
I truly think this
was one of the most
memorable nights of my life.
I had you and
Jordan Peterson over
just two weeks or so before
my first son was born.
And David and I were
basically able to ask you two
everything about life
and about parenting.
- Oh, about parenting, yes.
- And we talked
about everything.
It was one of the
most, I mean, truly,
it was one of the
most meaningful
conversations in my life.
- That's nice.
- And we realized, remember
what we realized that night,
about me, you, and Jordan,
that we have 14 years
separating each of us.
I was 46 at the
time, Jordan was 60,
and you were 74 at the time,
which is just sort
of interesting that
there's the same-
- Oh, that is fascinating.
- But you said, as, you know,
we were about to have kids,
and you said to me
something to the effect of,
"You better enjoy it now."
- Yeah, well, I
was more specific.
- Yeah, can you
clear it up for me?
- Well, but yes.
Look, I'm a big, big believer
in acknowledging reality.
I don't sugarcoat, and
I don't make worse.
And as I was saying
to you beforehand,
and I think I might
write a column on this.
The notion that you can
have it all is absurd.
And when the feminist
movement said to women,
you could have it all, it
was one of the indications
that it was an
immature movement.
Immature in terms of
thought and emotion, even.
You can have some of everything,
you can't have everything.
If you want to be a
parent, and you did,
and Dave did, obviously,
that you guys, you
wanted to be parents.
That means that happy-go-lucky,
let's do whatever we want,
anytime we want life is over.
- It is over, man.
- It's over, I'm sorry.
And so many immature
people, young people today,
don't want to give that up.
They think that will bring
them happiness in the long run.
It's fun on any given
day, but the long run,
to not have children,
to not have the prospect
of grandchildren
is such a poorer life.
- Do you think you can
have it for moments,
have everything for moments?
- Yes, that's right.
- 'Cause I will
tell you one thought
that I'm having a
lot lately is that,
and I don't wanna jinx it,
I almost don't wanna
say this out loud.
I'm sure there's a
Yiddish word for it.
- Yeah?
- I have the stuff that I
want in my life right now.
My life is good, my
family life is good.
- You're blessed.
- My home is good.
- That's exactly right.
- My work is good, my
colleagues are good.
- That's right, I have that.
- But it's making
me a little nervous.
- Oh, oh, I don't have that.
- Which I've, no,
I never had that.
- Okay, so you are, this
is almost redundant,
a neurotic Jew.
- No, I'm not a neurotic Jew.
- [Dennis] Okay, fine.
If you think that-
- I'm not neurotic,
I'm not neurotic.
- Okay, okay, I don't know.
- I don't have that.
- I don't think you are.
- I don't have that thing, yeah.
- Oh, if you don't
have it, then,
oh, I thought you were
saying you do have it.
- No, no, no, no, I
have this notion now-
- The notion that
you're jinxing it-
- Yeah.
- Is neurotic.
- That's neurotic?
- Okay, yes.
- Wow, we found my neurosis.
- No, you're a pretty good-
- Because you know me, I'm
not a neurotic person as-
- No, that's correct.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You are about as
healthy a guy as I know,
in all seriousness.
- Right.
- But I never, I have,
quote-unquote, it all,
in that sense.
But I don't have it all
because I've given
up X, Y, and Z
for family, for career,
for intimacy, for friends.
You know, do I wanna
sleep in many Saturdays?
Of course I do.
But I teach at the
synagogue that I,
that Allen Estrin, Steve
Marmon, and I founded in LA.
But it's worth it because
I love that community.
So I so long ago made peace
with, you give up to gain.
You know, it's so funny.
People say, "No pain, no gain."
And they always mean it
with regard to exercise.
It's true with
everything in life.
You are learning it now.
And by the way, wait till
they get to be teenagers.
- Oh, no.
- Then you may end up neurotic.
- Oh, really?
- They may cause it. (laughs)
- It's so funny, because I
really don't consider myself
a neurotic person, and I've-
- [Dennis] No, you're not.
- And I usually,
and I don't worry,
I generally don't worry about,
I worry about the
future of the world.
- Oh.
- You know?
- That's my answer when
people say, "How are you?"
For years, I've been saying,
"Better than my country."
- So you and I share that.
I'm not worried about that much
in my day-to-day
life, basically.
Especially now I'm not.
But I worry about the
nature of the world,
where the country's heading.
- Oh, no, no.
That is a legit worry.
- Is it?
You've got a couple years on me.
How do you, where do you put-
- Oh, it's not even a matter-
- Where do you put that in life?
It's just with you
all the time, right?
- This one is not a matter
of a couple of years on you.
This I knew at a very early age,
the most cultured country in
the world built Auschwitz.
There's this old question,
how did the people who
gave us Beethoven and Bach
give us Auschwitz?
And I always found, it's
an interesting question,
but it's somewhat
of a non-sequitur.
Why does having
Bach and Beethoven
inoculate you against
becoming evil?
The ease with which a
civilization can turn morally,
that's what Germany taught.
And I see that happening
in the United States.
This I always believed
was the kindest country.
I know it has
rotten people in it,
just as rotten countries
have kind people in it.
But as a country, when people
wanted help after earthquakes,
they didn't ask for Belgium.
When people used a flag
to rebel for liberty,
like in Hong Kong, they
didn't take the Swedish flag.
- Right.
- But look what's happening.
- Do you think that
it maybe is just
exactly what was going to happen
with the nature of the internet?
That because all of
us have the world
in our pocket all the time,
and the ability to get
information out all the time,
and fight all the time,
and see things that we
didn't see all the time,
and see behind the curtain
of the lies of the media,
just the litany of things
that now we all have
sort of stuffed in our brains,
that the moment that we're at
was in some ways inevitable?
- Because of the internet?
- Yeah, because there's just
so much information there.
- Yeah.
- It feeds the division,
the algorithms,
all of those things that
we were gonna get to
this weird spot in
some ways almost-
- No, I see the decline
in my beloved country
as independent of the internet.
I was at Columbia
University in the '70's.
That's way before the internet.
I was taught that America
was an imperialist country.
I was taught that men and
women are basically the same.
And I even wrote
about it in the '80's.
The roots way, way
transcend internet.
- So you think it was
inevitable anyway,
because of the education system-
- I do, I do, I sorry to say.
- Or the institutional collapse,
but not necessarily
'cause of the internet?
- Well, at Columbia, there
were kids spelling America
in graffiti with a K.
- A K, yeah.
- That's 1972.
And I remember thinking,
"Are you out of your mind?
Do you know what
fascism is, or Nazism?"
'Cause that was the
German spelling, you know,
as if we're becoming
Nazi Germany.
- [Dave] So how do you...
- Reagan explained it.
We are always one generation
away from losing freedom.
Deuteronomy explains it.
You know, I have my series
of Bible commentaries.
- Right there.
- Yeah, I'm very touched, yes.
I am touched.
- Well, this is your-
- My life's project.
- It's your studio.
- Oh, okay, so I'm less touched.
- You know whose name's
on the building, right?
- Okay, yeah,
that's a good point.
I didn't think of that.
It just shows, I'm
not Mr. Prima Donna.
But Deuteronomy says, "You
will talk about these things."
That is God's teachings.
"When you lie down,
when you rise up,
when you walk by the way,
when you go to sleep."
In other words, if you
don't teach your children
good values all the
time, it's over.
And that's what happened.
And I'll tell you who did it,
and I knew it when I was a kid.
It was the generation we
call the Greatest Generation.
They were the greatest
generation in many ways,
but not as parents.
Their motto, and by the way,
I said this in my 20's,
when I started lecturing.
I would look at these people,
my parents' generation.
I'd say, "You always say
you give our generation
everything you didn't have.
The problem is you didn't give
us everything you did have."
Which was love of
country, love of God,
the self-control,
and all those values.
- So if you saw that when you
were 20, so now we're talking,
you know, 50 some odd years ago,
you must really see
it when, you know,
so I'm a Gen X guy.
So at 47, I'm right
now in the thick of
what is supposed to
be the group of people
running the show at this point.
And yet we're not.
We have an 80 plus year
old who's president
and another 80
plus year old who,
and I'm not an ageist of course,
but the shift has not occurred
where we have sort of younger
people running things.
I also think that is adding
now to some of the tension.
- Oh, I wonder.
I don't know why, exactly,
'cause I remember,
and I'm not saying this
'cause I'm old now,
but I remember the
motto, one of the stupid,
many stupid mottos of my
generation, the Baby Boomers,
"Never trust anyone over 30."
And I was 20 when
I first heard it.
And I thought, "What are
you, out of your mind?"
I trust Moses.
He's 3,000 years old.
I remember thinking that.
- That's funny.
- He's really over 30.
But what a stupid line is that?
Let's say everyone over 60
was removed from all
public office in America.
Nothing would change.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Nothing.
- I think there's a slim chance
we'd get some change
on the margins.
Maybe just, just getting rid of
some of the, like, dead wood.
- Yeah, so you'd
have young fools.
- Yeah, we would just get the-
- We'd just have middle aged
fools instead of old fools.
- Yeah.
Well, look, it's so
funny, 'cause you're
doing this with me.
We're talking about
the ills of the world.
But you always have
a smile on your face.
I see you at my house, you
have a smile on your face.
- Oh, you know why, okay.
- And you've been talking
about happiness forever.
- That's right.
- So it's an
interesting dichotomy.
You're telling me, on one hand,
you're worried about the
world, and I know you are.
It's your life's
work to correct that.
And yet you really,
if someone said to me,
"Who's the happiest
person you know?
It's probably you.
- Right.
Well, you know-
- And yet there's a whole
other series of people
that think you're very scary.
You're a right wing
maniac or something.
- Right, yes.
Like they know me, or
even know what I say.
They got all their material
from another left site.
- [Dave] Right.
- It's very, you'll
find this very touching.
'cause you're very
close to Jordan.
So, so Jordan
Peterson, obviously,
he was at a PragerU gala
about a year and a half ago.
And we had a wonderful dialogue.
And I'm, of course,
a big fan of Jordan.
And he, to his credit,
stayed afterwards
to take pictures with
people and talk with people.
And I was very
impressed with that,
'cause a lot of speakers leave.
And I do what he does,
I stay, I hang around.
But of course, at a Prager
event, I'm gonna hang around.
Okay.
Anyway, he walked over to me,
I've never told this publicly.
I don't think he'd mind,
but you're so close to him.
It's mind-blowing
what you just said.
He said something to this
effect, I'm paraphrasing.
"You know, Dennis,
I don't know anybody
who is as intense about
the big issues as you are,
and who was as happy as you
are, who was as lighthearted."
And I never thought of that,
that I'm sort of unique.
I don't know if I'm unique,
but sort of unique in that way.
A, it's my temperament,
but B, I cultivated it.
I hate being unhappy.
I really hate it.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And I am able to
compartmentalize.
That's why my answer,
"Better than my country,"
is such an honest answer.
Am I quote-unquote depressed
about the state of America?
Yes.
But am I depressed?
No.
- Right.
And a lot of people
can't do that these days.
- That's right, they can't.
- They can't disconnect
those things.
- Well, that's right, and
they can't compartmentalize.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- If you can't compartmentalize,
you cannot be happy.
Otherwise, every human being
who has had tragedy is doomed.
You know how many parents I
know who have lost a child?
A lot of them have been able,
and it's truly to
their great credit,
to walk around with an
essentially happy disposition.
And that's the more searing
pain a human can have,
which you can only now imagine.
It's the ultimate nightmare.
- We had to take
Luke to the hospital.
Out of nowhere, one night
something wasn't right.
He was a little pale and
kind of closing his eyes.
We thought something
was going on.
And maybe I said
this once on camera.
This is about six months ago.
We were in the car,
and I spoke to God
to whatever extent
that I speak to God,
and I said, "You could
take me right now."
Like, take me instead of him.
- Right, just don't
take him, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, you know, that
gives me the chills.
When I brought my first
son home from the hospital,
I remember getting
out of the car,
crossing the street into
my house and thinking,
"I have never been as
unafraid as I am now
if a car were to come.
All I know is this
child will be safe,
and I'm okay if I'm hit."
- Hmm, wow, from day one.
- It's what you had just then,
you had the same exact thing.
I'm just echoing what you said.
- Yeah.
- If you can't compartmentalize,
you can't achieve happiness.
There's too much pain
in one's own life
or in the life of
the society that if,
and by the way,
compartmentalize is a good term
because what sank the Titanic
was that the
compartments did in fact
leak one into the next.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Had they not, it
would not have sunk.
- Is that something
that you think,
and I actually don't wanna
do much political stuff
with you today, but is
that something you think
conservative-minded
people can do better
than lefties,
liberals, whatever?
- Yes, because our whole
life isn't politics.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- If the country
were in good shape,
I wouldn't talk about
politics five minutes a day.
- Yeah.
- I am forced to, 'cause I
want to help save this country.
But that is their meaning.
Revolution is their meaning.
That's not our meaning.
We get meaning from a whole
bunch of things, even hobbies.
- Yeah. It's funny 'cause when
I had you and Jordan over,
and that night, it
was mostly focused on
family and whatever.
But like, had we
talked politics,
it would've almost
seemed ridiculous.
The word Trump did not come up.
The name DeSantis
did not come up.
- [Dennis] That's right.
- And it would've seemed
sort of ridiculous.
Why would I waste my
time with you guys
talking about that stuff?
Not to say it isn't important,
but it is a
compartment, not the-
- Yes.
But it is, the further
the left you go,
the more making
revolution is everything.
And therefore politics
is everything.
And that's a, sorry.
It's very embarrassing when my
own phone rumbles, you know.
- Yeah this could be-
- It's-
- What could be going on here?
- Yeah. (laughs)
It's really a riot.
You know what it's
gonna be, by the way.
- Could be the Prager people,
they need you to do something.
- No, no, here's the joke.
You know what it'll
say on my phone?
Scam Likely.
(Dave laughing)
I get more calls from Mr.
Likely than from my wife.
- They're trying to get you now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It could be Sue sending
you a picture of my children.
Anything's possible.
- That is entirely
accurate, yes.
- Anything's possible.
I think almost every time
I have you on camera,
I repeat the same story,
but I think it's
always worth repeating.
And we can only do it
for a moment if you want.
But the time that when I did
the "Why I Left the Left" video
and we were just getting
to know each other
and it was the first time
I was on your radio show,
I think that afternoon,
and I was dealing with a lot
of hate and all that stuff.
And I said to you,
and I didn't know you
the way I know you now.
And I said, "Dennis, you know,
what do you do about
the hate and security
and all that stuff?"
And you said to me, it
was just so perfect.
You said, "Dave, you
know, I can't do,"
This is not a great
Dennis Prager impression,
but you said, "Dave, you know,
I'm doing my show from the
same studio for 30 years,
and I guess one day somebody
could be waiting for me outside
and hack me with a machete.
But when it's your time to
go, it's your time to go."
And I just, to me,
that sums you up.
Like that, and you're smiling
about that right now, like-
- By the way, it's an
extremely rational effect.
This notion that I
can protect myself
if somebody really wants
to harm me, is absurd.
How often do you read,
"And so and so and his three
bodyguards were killed."
(laughs)
- Right, right, right.
- You know, for whatever reason,
I do elicit a lot of hate,
but not that level,
for whatever reason.
And I'm not sure why.
I'm a pretty effective
voice against the left.
But I'm not complaining,
certainly, about that fact.
But I'm anti worrying.
Worrying truly is worthless.
I have a whole theory like
I do on almost everything.
Here's my theory on worrying.
People should monitor, how
often have they worried,
and the thing they worried
about actually occurred.
You'll find what a small
percentage of time that is.
So then you've truly just
created misery for yourself
for no reason.
And if it does happen,
did the worrying help?
- Usually not, I'm gonna guess.
- [Dennis] Yes, no help at all.
- It probably made it
worse to some extent.
- Yes.
I'm not saying you
don't take precautions
and you don't, you know, I
have earthquake insurance.
I had earthquake
insurance before the
Northridge earthquake.
- What do you do about a society
that you're worried about,
as someone that
doesn't wanna worry
and doesn't wanna be neurotic
and wants to fight
for the things?
Like, what do you do?
For the average person
that's watching this,
or that does care
about politics,
that caress about the stuff?
- So I have an answer.
- That feels kind of-
- I actually have an answer.
The only antidote to
worry, or better, to misery
over the state of the
society is to fight.
That is the only antidote.
Tuning out doesn't work.
Because they'll come to
you where you're tuned out.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You think you're tuning
out at a baseball game?
Then they're gonna
put Black Lives Matter
on the pitchers mound.
Or in the, you know, in the
field goal area, you know,
what is it, touchdown, end zone.
- End zone.
- In the end zone.
So you can't tune
out, it doesn't work.
You have children,
you're gonna tune out,
and then they come home
and they hate your guts
'cause you voted Republican?
Society's gonna
catch up with you.
The only antidote is to fight.
- So as you see now,
the country going in
different directions.
And I mean that sort
of philosophically,
but also geographically, right?
I mean, I lived here.
I'm one of a million
some odd people
that have now left California
and moved to Florida.
To me, when I come back here,
I feel no, it's great to see you
and some of my friends here,
but I feel no connection
with this place anymore.
- That's fascinating.
- And I don't mean this as
cold as it's gonna sound,
but I don't really
care about it.
- Yeah.
- Meaning believe
why should I care?
If they've made their choice.
Now I get, there's millions
of good people here.
- 8 million, there are 8
million Republicans here.
- Right, right.
More than any
other state, right?
- Yes.
- So, how do you
piece that together
in terms of the United
States of America?
- Listen, I want you to know,
I am periodically
praised by strangers.
"Oh, you know, I
want you to know,
really salute you for staying
in California and fighting."
I'm not in California.
I'm fighting, but
California is lost, okay?
- Yeah.
- It is a given.
A vicious party runs my state,
and Oregon and Washington,
and Illinois, and New York.
I mean, a lot of states.
Minnesota.
So I am here because there are
so many people I
love who are here.
And as I mentioned, I
created a synagogue,
which I am very devoted to.
You promised me to
create me one if I-
- I told you I would
be the founding member
if you moved to Florida.
I do mean it.
- I believe you.
- I do mean it.
- It's not not tempting.
- I missed, you know,
we just went through
the High Holidays here.
- Yes.
- And I missed going
to services here.
- My service, yeah, yeah.
Well, so I have a very,
very wonderful life here.
It's a very odd, I wouldn't
say cognitive dissonance.
It's just an odd
contradiction, so to speak,
to have a great life
in a miserable place.
I acknowledge it.
Newsom just announced, I mean,
that he is vetoing a
bill that would allow,
or creating or signing a bill,
that would fine any school
that banned any book
about race or sex.
There is no time in the
history of the world
that schools have not
banned certain books.
- Right.
- When I was a kid-
- Fifth grade library.
- Yes, that's right.
There was a children's
section in the library.
That means a lot of
books were banned.
- You mean your elementary
school didn't have "Mein Kampf?"
- Well, listen,
here's the irony.
- Oh dear.
- My parents probably would've,
"You wanna read Mein Kampf,
then just read Mein Kampf.
But we're not gonna give
you fellatio books."
- Right.
- I mean, this is, robbing
children of their innocence
is somebody, what was the term?
I've called the left
sick for some time now,
and I mean it literally.
A pathocracy.
It was a good term.
- Yeah.
- I don't know who came
up with it, it's not mine.
- Right, 'cause it's like
this pathological thinking
that then gets
institutionalized.
- Yes, that's right.
- Yeah.
- That's what it is.
You know, we're gonna
have five-year-olds
with guys dancing
in women's clothing?
Oh, you'll get a
kick out of this.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- So I don't remember the verse,
but there is a verse
in Deuteronomy.
"A man shall not wear
women's clothing,
and a woman shall not
wear men's clothing."
I have to remember the numbers.
Deuteronomy
something, something.
So there are a lot of
Christians who will have,
I think it's from
John 1:8, is it?
Does anybody here know
that there's a famous one
about God giving his one
only son to the world?
- I love that.
The biblical scholar's
asking the lighting guy
if he knows what-
- [Crew Member] John 3:16, yeah.
- Oh, very good.
- John what?
- [Crew Member] 3:16.
- 3:16?
Yeah.
So John 3:16.
- New Testament
- And it worked.
- I don't worked as well
as the Old Testament.
- Man, you are a pro.
- I knew it'd work.
- All right, you're a pro.
I rehearsed Nathan on that one.
- Yeah, that was good.
- So a lot of people
have a bumper sticker,
that say John 3:16.
I wanna have a bumper
sticker, Deuteronomy this,
whatever that is.
And then people say,
"What the hell is that?"
And they'll look it
up and, you know,
people don't know that
the Bible forbids that,
as an example.
- Yeah.
Then you'll have a real
problem in California.
Well, no one here is religious,
so it would be all right.
- Well, yeah, first
of all, you're right,
most people don't know
what Deuteronomy is.
- Yeah.
- So I could put it up there
and it wouldn't matter.
- You know, speaking
of the gender thing,
you'll find this interesting,
just at a philosophical
level, I think.
I was, a few months ago,
we had my sister
and her kids over,
and she's got three young kids.
And their middle son
is about six years old.
And I'm sitting in
the pool with him,
and it suddenly struck him
that there's no
mother at my house.
And he said to
me, he said to me,
"You have Justin
and Luke are here,
but there's no mommy here."
And he said,
"Where's the mommy?"
And I had this really
interesting moment because-
- Yeah, what do you answer?
- So my answer was basically
I grabbed a ball or something
and I threw it to like,
change the topic for a second,
because I knew it was not
my place to give the answer.
- Oh, that's very,
that's touching.
- I punted it for now,
but the irony of course,
well, because the irony
is, he's my nephew.
I love him. I have his
best interests in mind,
but it's not my
place as the uncle
to say when it is for him to
learn about such things, right?
- Right.
- So I said to my sister as
they were leaving, I said,
"Hey, by the way, he
asked me this question.
You have no pressure from me.
I'm just saying he asked,
and we'll see if it
ever comes up again."
As far as I know it hasn't.
But I really thought I
did the right thing there.
And I suspect the way
you're nodding at me,
probably I guess you agree.
- Yes, well, it was
a very noble answer.
Well, a noble non-answer.
You see, you are
a sort of a victim
of what the left has done
with the whole LGBT thing.
Do you know, I only
wish, it is recorded.
Somebody who did 20 years
of research would find it.
At least 15 years ago, I said
on a number of occasions,
why is there a T with LGB?
What does T have to do with LGB?
Nothing.
And L and G claim,
"This is how we are."
What does gay have
to do with trans?
And the country is not
comfortable with trans,
and correctly so.
- At the very minimum,
with children.
- At the very minimum, yes.
- Put aside how
someone feels an adult-
- Well, no, you're 30
years old and you say,
you know, have a
nice life, fine.
But cutting off 18 year
old girl's breasts,
it is our form of
clitoridectomy.
What some Muslim, many Muslims,
but not all, in Africa do,
where they cut off a girl's
clitoris at, I don't know,
12 years old, whatever it is.
We are no better.
I mean the people need to under,
we have devolved, in the
course of a few years
to the level of
the clitoridectomy.
- And then they call
it affirming care,
which is an incredible
play on words, right?
- [Dennis] Totally.
- It's the least affirming
thing you could ever do.
- Right.
If you're gender-affirming,
what you say to a six-year-old
who says she's a boy, we wanna
affirm that you're a girl.
That's gender affirming.
- That would be affirming.
- [Dennis] Yes.
- Chopping their genitals,
probably not that affirming.
- No.
- Yeah.
But generally speaking,
conservative, and again,
conservative as I say it with
this wide sense of that word,
are not very good at controlling
language around this stuff.
Right? We're always playing
defense on this, right?
They used to, "Don't say gay."
And then we're all like, "Ah,
what do we do with that?"
- They own language.
Look, you know the viral
video with me on Bill Maher?
- Yes, we played it many times,
and you deserve a
lot of credit for it.
- Well, just for the 2% of
America that is unaware of it,
less than four years
ago, I was on his show.
He said, "Oh, you know,
Trump lies, Trump lies."
I said, "Well, it doesn't
compare to the left's lies."
He goes, "Like what?"
Like America's systemically
racist, and men menstruate.
- And they gave it big laugh.
- Everybody laughed.
- Yeah.
- He laughed, the panel
laughed, and the whole audience,
and people have seen it.
And he goes, "Dennis,
where'd you get that from?"
It went from, "What the
hell are you talking about?"
To, "Of course men
menstruate," in two years.
- They are literally-
- That's how much
they own the language.
- They are literally putting
tampons in boys' restrooms.
- Oh, absolutely.
- In high schools.
- That's correct, yes.
This is the generation
that's gonna have to
fight for America
perhaps one day.
- Do you think there's gonna be
a lot of people
that are young now
that are going to be
seriously angry and resentful?
- Yes, it's already happening.
- Yeah.
That when they're putting their
parents into old age homes,
they are not going to the
Cadillac of old age homes.
I mean, they are
gonna be basically
pushing them off the bridge.
I mean that somewhat
metaphorically,
but that they are
just gonna say,
"Wow, you did none of the things
that were important to
protect me in this world."
- Well, it's already happening
where you have a fair
number of these poor souls
who had their breasts cut off,
or their male genitals cut off.
And they're suing the
despicable therapists
who see them for
an hour and say,
"Yeah, oh no, you're
definitely a boy."
Absolutely.
- Jordan calls them butchers,
and now he's got the Canadian
Board of psychiatry after him.
- That's right.
- Trying to take
away his license.
- Well, Canada,
you know. (laughs)
I have no idea if this
is a consolation or not.
Canada's worse.
When Justin Trudeau said
to the striking truckers,
which is now like
ancient history,
but it's a year and a half
ago or two years maybe,
he said, "You must get a
vaccine or you're fired."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And they said no, that's
why they went on strike.
And they could not have
access to their own money
in their own bank accounts.
That's scary.
- Do you think in some respects
these guys are
overplaying their hand
and they may cause enough of it?
- Yes.
- Yeah, all right, that's nice.
- I think if, yes, you
are right, it's nice.
'Cause I do not look at life
through rose-colored glasses.
I think the trans issue,
and I think that there is,
you know, I'm thinking
of so many things.
That's why I am moving
from one to another.
But let me be more careful.
If the left founders, it
will be on the trans issue.
Most Americans are not
prepared to say men give birth.
They know that there is a
certain big lie involved there,
and they're not
prepared to go that far.
They do not believe that
five-year-olds should be taught
that you might be a boy
or you might be a girl.
They do not believe
five-year-olds
should have drag
queen story hours
or very sexual books read
to them in sixth grade.
And the proof I have is
that the New York Times
is starting to
publish a few columns
from, you know,
guest columnists,
saying, you know, we
have to understand
there's a middle road here.
And they just had a piece
in the New York Times.
"Well, you know,
I'm no right winger
and I can't stand
the right wing,
but, you know, we're going
too far on the left."
- But is that their trick?
Is that the left and
the machine's trick
of always maintaining power?
Meaning they drag us all
to the precipice of hell
with all of this stuff,
and then suddenly,
right before we
go off the cliff,
the New York Times
pulls back a tiny bit,
but they've already
dragged us this far.
Another one you could give
is right here in this state.
They were about to pass a bill
in the California legislature
about, if you did not affirm
your child's gender identity,
they were gonna
literally let the state
take your children away.
So Gavin Newsom at the
last second vetoed it,
not because he doesn't
give into the woke
and push the woke
in every moment,
but it's their way of suddenly-
- You may be 100% right.
- So we drag you and drag you.
- That's that-
- Welcome to the inferno.
- Right.
- And then at the last moment,
they give you a little fire
retardant or something, so you-
- No, no, that's fair.
That may well be.
So even then putting
that argument aside,
I do believe that this could
be their Achilles heel.
The problem is the liberal.
My problem is not the left.
The left is the left.
As I say almost every
day on my radio show,
the left votes its values,
the right votes its values,
liberals do not
vote their values.
Liberals, almost my whole
extended family is liberal.
Sweet people, and I mean that.
And they are convinced
the right is their enemy.
(speaking foreign language)
It's a very famous
line in French.
"There are no
enemies on the left."
That is what the
liberal believes.
All my enemies are on the right.
- And we see this consistently.
I mean, a guy like Bill Maher,
who was in essence
mocking you for that.
- [Dennis] Yeah.
- And I brought it
up to, didn't I,
I think I brought it up to Bill
when I sat down with him on
his podcast about that moment.
- [Dennis] Yeah.
- And I think he kind of like
whisked it off a little bit.
- That's interesting.
- But he then,
just two weeks ago,
was saying that he wishes,
he wants Gavin Newsom
to run for president.
And it's like, he's not a
crazy leftist lunatic, right?
- [Dennis] Right.
- You would describe him
basically, right, as a-
- Right, but Newsom is
a crazy leftist lunatic.
- Thus prove-
- And he wants,
well, that is proof.
That is exactly right.
- It's proof, right.
So you are saying, in
essence you're saying,
the true lefties, they're
telling us what they believe
and they're doing it.
- Right.
- It's the waffle people-
- That's right.
- That, yeah.
But how do we get that? Hey,
I was one, and here I am.
So there is a way to get 'em.
- So my view of people
like you is this.
Whenever someone
comes over to me
at an airport, as
a classic example,
or obviously after a speech.
"Just want you to know,
Dennis, you changed my life."
And I give them an answer,
which they may think
I'm just being sweet.
I swear before God,
I mean it literally.
I tell them, and I say to you,
"You get at least
50% of the credit."
Because I have been
saying these things,
and I'm just one example.
There are so many,
Jordan and others.
But I have been saying
this for decades,
and vast numbers of people,
their lives have not changed.
(Dave laughing)
So obviously, you have
to get half the credit.
If Dave Rubin
personified humanity,
we would have no troubles.
- It's kind of funny, I was
just thinking, you know,
after touring with
Jordan for so long,
and I've done plenty
of events with you,
I've never seen someone go up
to either of you and Jordan
been like, "You know, I've
been listening to you guys
for a long time, I've
read all the books.
Watched all of you-"
- Right, no effect.
- "Didn't do anything
for me." (laughs)
- (laughs) Exactly, exactly.
- Has anyone ever done
anything like that?
Like, "You know, Dennis?"
- Yes.
- This happiness thing, yeah?
- Okay, I have,
yes, as it happens.
So I did an event in Minnesota
for my local station
in Minneapolis.
- Oh God, it was
Ilhan Omar, wasn't it?
She read your book and just
said, "All right, Jew."
- No, no, this was,
this is related.
It's not exactly that.
So the event was at a very,
very plush cigar lounge.
And it was really just for how
many people can you fit in,
so about 100 people.
They paid, you know, good
money for the station
to raise money, and
I go there, I speak,
and people were sitting outside.
It was not obviously winter.
And so there were young,
a lot of, you know,
guys in their 20's
sitting out there
and having a drink or
smoking a cigar or both.
And a guy looks at me
and he goes, "Prager?"
I go, "Yes."
And the way he asked it, I then
said, "Is that good or bad?"
And he said, "Bad."
- Ah.
- And that was basically it.
- That was it?
- Yes.
- 'Cause it just never happened.
- It was just hilarious.
That's the closest I've ever
gotten to your, you know,
"I just want you to know, I've
heard you all these years,
you haven't had one, like,
this much impact on me."
- "Happiness, meh, it
didn't really work for me."
- "I'm as miserable
as ever." (laughs)
- That also, I think,
tells us something
a little bit about how
people behave, I guess.
I guess this is what
I was trying to say
about the online thing earlier.
That there's a behavior pattern
that's developing online.
Jordan also talks about this,
that it's becoming pathological.
That you can just all day long,
"Hate you, hate you,
you're mean, blah, blah."
All these awful things.
Where in real life
this sort of thing
just simply does not happen.
Even if you go to an event
where you're protested,
you know, it's like they'll
scream and whatever,
but it's, you know,
the idea that it would
really escalate or
something like that.
It's not non-existent,
but, you know.
- [Dennis] Right.
- The keyboard has given us
a certain level of a
force field, in a way.
- What is depressing
is obviously
has nothing to do with violence.
But I actually read comments.
Not just on things about
me or things I write,
I read comments all the time.
That is really an
insight into the public,
'cause they're anonymous.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And especially in the case
of the New York Times readers,
you have to be a New
York Times subscriber
to make a comment.
- Right, so that to me would be
a more valuable version of it.
- Oh, that's right.
It is very valuable.
And stuff that I see there.
I'll give you an example.
I did a whole show on this.
Some writer wrote
about how I think is,
I presume a woman, she's
not gonna have children
because of climate change, and-
- Oh, I remember this.
This was a couple
months ago, right?
- Oh, even more than that.
But within the last year.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And so I read,
I always click on,
that you can click
on three things,
newest, New York Times editor's
choice, reader's choice.
I always click on
reader's choice.
The ones that the reader,
the comments the
readers most like.
And one after another
went like this.
"More than anything,
I have always hoped
to have grandchildren.
But my daughter,"
usually their daughter,
my daughter, or my
daughter and her husband,
"Because of global warming,
are not having children.
And I salute them
for that decision."
That is what I mean.
- That's pathology.
- Jews after the
Holocaust had children.
And these people based
on computer models
at Oxford are not?
These are sickos.
- [Dave] Yeah, but deprogramming
somebody from that level-
- Oh no, it's hopeless.
- Do you think that's
in some ways also
why there's such an
assault on children?
Because if you can
break the child,
in this case, let's
say an 18 year old girl
who suddenly is saying
she can't have children
because of climate change,
that that's a very easy way
of then breaking the adult
who may have been more,
less susceptible to
these ideas just by age.
You know what I mean?
Like, if you get the child,
now the parent has to kind of
defend that to some extent.
- Yeah, well, only
because parents are weak.
- Yeah.
- If my child said,
"I'm not having children
because of global warming,"
I'd say I was a pretty,
I'm a failure as a parent.
If you think that
way, I really failed.
The idea, I have real
contempt for this.
Because it's my child,
I will not stand up
for what I believe,
then you don't believe
what you believe in.
I love my children.
I'm not gonna compromise
on what I believe
because my child
feels differently.
And maybe that's
part of the reason
my children still respect me,
'cause they know that's true.
- Do you think
it's possible that
we're not a serious
enough country anymore
to fix some of
these grand things?
The big worry things?
The the real sort
of slow decline?
That we want a show
maybe more than truth,
that we want a showman maybe
more than someone
who's competent.
That it just may be a piece
of what we've all become
that isn't something
that's able to fix this.
- Well, in this sense,
it's not internet.
In this sense, I've
said all of my life,
the two great
calamities in America
were college and television.
Before college, widespread
college, and before television,
Americans were more
serious, were more mature,
were more grown up.
That Oprah Winfrey is so
popular and is so not profound,
you know, well,
that's your truth.
She's a big fan of that phrase.
There's no such
thing as your truth.
The Oregon Education
Department announced that.
If you believe there's only
one right answer in math,
you are a white supremacist.
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah.
- Which by the
way, you know what
the irony of that
whole statement is?
If only whites believe-
- Right.
- That there's one
right answer in math,
then whites are supreme.
- (laughs) Right.
- That's the irony of
the idiocy of that.
Blacks should be
the first people
to be pissed at the Oregon
Education Department.
"You are telling
me that if I think
there's a one right
answer in math,
that means I'm a
white supremacist?"
- But also to combine that,
to combine the obvious
mathematical truth.
- Yeah, that's right. (laughs)
- To a racial-
- Right, yes.
- Yeah.
But we're hit with
this everywhere.
- Everywhere.
- Yeah.
So, I mean, is it possible
we're just not serious
enough as a nation
at this point, then, to
actually turn around?
Meaning that we want the
thing that gives us clicks.
- Okay.
- You know, that-
- The only thing that
makes me pessimistic
is the ons, as opposed
to were concerned-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Is free speech.
The left, two things.
One, there was no
instance in history,
and that was my field,
leftism at Columbia.
There is no instance in history
of the left allowing dissent.
You could argue from
the French revolution,
certainly from the
Russian revolution.
Wherever the left is in
charge, dissent is suppressed.
There is no liberals
allowed dissent
and conservatives
allowed dissent.
Leftists have never
So that's point number one.
Point number two, if dissent
is allowed, we will win.
They can only win by
suppressing free speech.
And I guess point number
three, 45% of Americans say,
young Americans say, "I
believe in free speech,
but not for hate speech."
They don't even understand
that means they don't
believe in free speech.
- [Dave] Right.
- If you want to
say, I am a Jew,
if you wanna say, "I hate Jews,"
you should be allowed
to say, "I hate Jews."
Because if I don't allow
you to say, "I hate Jews,"
there is no end to
what I will not allow.
It's why the anger,
the ADL which has done
more to foment antisemitism
than to fight it.
- Well, they became a
leftist organization-
- That's true.
- Rather than a
liberal organization,
which is what they were-
- And rather than a
Jewish organization.
- Yeah.
- Even, that's right.
So Musk is correct
in attacking the ADL.
And now all these left wing Jews
are calling him an antisemite.
It so angers me, and I've
written a book on antisemitism,
which has been in
print for 40 years.
- What do you
think of the notion
that every institution that
isn't specifically conservative
will always become leftist?
- That's fascinating.
- There's an actual
phrase for it.
But that, you know, in essence,
like if you looked at the ACLU,
which was a liberal organization
defending the Nazis' right
to march in Skokie, Illinois-
- You know, I never-
- It's become become a
wacky leftist organization.
- I've never thought of that.
That is a very
intelligent point.
Can I think of a liberal, as
opposed to individual liberals
like Alan Dershowitz.
- [Dave] Right.
- But can I think of
a liberal institution
that has not gone left?
I cannot.
- And by the way, a lot of the
conservative ones end up too,
but they have at least
some defenses, right?
- You mean they end up
liberal too, you mean?
- They end up probably
shifting more left over time,
to some extent.
- Yeah, but we have
honest to goodness
conservative institutions.
That's clear.
But your point is frightening.
- But it kind of makes sense.
- It does, and that-
- Look what you
said about Columbia.
- Well, Columbia was
left when I was there,
it wasn't even liberal.
But so that raises the
important question.
Why does that happen?
Why aren't liberals
guardians of liberalism?
Do you have an answer to that?
- I mean, I've been noodling
this one for quite some time
and it comes up on
my show all the time.
And I think it probably
is connected to belief.
- That's correct.
That's my ultimate thesis.
- I see no way around it.
- There is none.
- You end up believing
in something.
You know, when I've discussed
this with Bill Maher,
when I hear him talking
about it, he always says,
"Well, I didn't leave the
left, the left left me."
And then he says the liberal
principles he believes in.
But he also would say
he's not a believer.
So he on one hand is telling
me, "I believe in liberalism."
But if you said to him,
"Are you a believer?"
You know, in a grand
sense, he would say no.
But you do believe in something.
You just told me what
you believe, liberalism.
- Yeah, but you told
me just 10 minutes ago
he supports Newsom,
who's a leftist.
- So I think he's
rather confused on-
- Yes he is.
- Well, no, it's not
that he's confused.
He's a brilliant guy.
The issue with him
really, and I would,
we've become friendly, so I
would say this to his face.
This isn't something, I'm
not speaking behind his back.
His issue I think is
that he's 67 years old,
worth an untold amount
of millions of dollars,
as a lifelong atheist,
unmarried with no kids,
he can afford to
have certain beliefs.
That I think maybe if he
had had kids and whatever,
I know that sounds
very judgment.
He discussed this a bit
with Jordan on his podcast.
But you know what I mean?
Like, if you're worth
a gajillion dollars
and only responsible
for yourself,
it's pretty easy probably
to have a series of beliefs
that don't really have
to get put into action.
He's not worried that
his kid's gonna come home
saying that his kid's a
girl, his son is a girl.
So you can sort of have
the belief that it's wrong,
but you can also vote in the
guy who will usher it in.
- Well, it raises also
other questions, like-
- I don't mean to make it about
him specifically, obviously.
- No, no, no, all right, well...
- But the liberalism and belief.
- I defended Bill Maher
when ABC kicked him off.
- Yeah.
- And he said disgusting
things about American pilots.
I had him on my show
to defend his right
to say disgusting things.
So I have a long, long track
record with Bill Maher, but-
- But the liberalism
and belief, yeah.
- The question with Bill Maher
that I would like to live
long enough, and I hope I do,
is 10 years from now,
will he look back at a
life with no wife, no kids,
and go, "That was a great life."
I don't know the answer, but...
It's not meant to
insult him at all,
'cause I actually admire
his taking on the left.
But it's a lack of emotional
depth, let's put it that way.
If you are 77 and go, you know,
"I really had a lot of fun.
What a great life."
- You know, you should
watch, I'll send it to you.
He did a sit down with
Jordan for about two hours
and they got into this,
and it's a tough thing
to sit across from
someone and talk about it,
much less Jordan Peterson.
And I think Jordan would
even say Bill might be
as close to the ability
to do that as possible.
- Oh, fascinating.
- Meaning he gave
everything to his career
and his comedy and
art, and blah blah.
- Right.
- And it's not to
say it's perfect,
because Jordan basically would
say it's almost impossible,
which is in essence
what you are saying.
But Bill might be as
close as it would-
- Okay, that's fair.
- Yeah.
- I want to go back to
the question you posed
and I then posed to you,
is why do all liberal
institutions end up left?
And your answer has
been my lifelong answer.
And here is part of the
reasoning we can give.
I just spoke at Arizona
State University again.
- Oh, I covered
this on the show,
because you're very
controversial, right?
You and Charlie Kirk went
there, Robert Kiyosaki.
- Well, yes, white nationalist.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I lost relatives
in the Holocaust,
but I'm a white nationalist.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- So I said to them, one second,
this is really important.
Oh yes.
Something I've been
saying for years.
Only secular people
say men give birth.
That should really give pause
to anyone who dismisses the
importance of the Bible,
religion, God, et cetera.
Only, not all, not everyone,
not every secular person
says men give birth.
But everyone who
says it is secular.
- [Dave] Right.
- So apparently there's
infinitely more idiotic ideas
coming from the
non-religious world
than the religious world.
You are brainwashed by
the left to believe that
it is religion
that is irrational
and has cockamamie ideas and
asks you to leave reason.
It's in fact the secular world
that has produced far
greater irrationality.
Or as I say to students
all the time, you know,
a hundred million
people, non-combatants,
were murdered in
the 20th century,
and every one of them
by a secular government.
- That sort of feels like
it should be the ending,
but it was a little dark.
Gimme something, gimme
the Dennis Prager smiley
we're ending this thing.
- I'll give you a fun story.
- Yeah, there we go.
- Okay.
Oh yeah, well you just,
I just told it to
you beforehand, but
I'll say it again.
You'll just have to laugh like
you heard it the first time.
- Oh no, it will be
even funnier this time.
- People will get
a kick out of this.
I just learned it
'cause it was just
my grandson's bar
mitzvah, in Florida.
And my son, his dad, my son,
told the story to the people
at the bar mitzvah party
prior to the Sabbath rituals.
And so he is known as DP3.
I'm DP1, Dennis Prager.
My son is DP2, David Prager.
And he is Daniel Prager, DP3.
And he's very proud of
that, which touches me.
- He'll probably be a
basketball player, that's nice.
- Yeah.
So when he was about eight,
my son told the story,
he said to his father,
"Daddy, if I have a child,
or when I have a child,
he's gonna be DP4."
So my son asked the logical
question, "Oh, really?
What will you name him?"
And he goes, "Daewon."
(laughs) Which is, you know,
generally understood
to be a Black name.
- Yeah.
- Often associated with sports.
- Which by the way, I don't
know if I told you inside,
it reminded me of his dad,
my son, also at eight.
I said, "David, what do you
wanna be when you grow up?"
And he said, "Black."
Because he had a picture of
Magic Johnson in in his room.
- (laughs) He skipped
basketball player
and went right to Black.
- That, that's correct.
Well that was the only avenue
to do what he really
wanted, presumably.
But it was so, he is in
good tradition, my grandson.
- [Dave] Dennis-
- But that's how we're
going to get DP4.
- And as much as I enjoy
these highly
intellectually stimulating
and deeply personal
philosophical
conversations with you-
- [Dennis] Yes.
- I also wish that
everything being equal,
I had been a Black
basketball player.
So here we are.
- That is a confession that
no one has heard from you
prior to this.
- How often do you fist bump?
- As often as I'm offered fists.
(laughs) I love you, Dave.
- Ah, that's good, that's good.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.